This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Many years ago, two researchers at Harvard noticed something interesting at their university's Peabody Museum of Natural History. It was a description about a pair of 19th century German glassmakers. It read, Descended from a long line of bohemian glass artists, Leopold Blaschka and his son Rudolf were gifted with such extraordinary skill and passion for their work that one might argue these attributes were indeed in their blood.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦达坦姆。许多年前，哈佛大学自然历史博物馆（Peabody Museum of Natural History）的两名研究人员在馆内注意到了一件有趣的事情。那是一段关于19世纪一对德国玻璃工匠的描述。上面写着：利奥波德·布拉斯奇卡（Leopold Blaschka）和他的儿子鲁道夫（Rudolf）源自一个长期从事波希米亚玻璃艺术的家族，他们天生拥有对工作的非凡技艺和热情，可以说这些特质确实融入了他们的血液之中。
The researchers Chihay Jang Sai and Mazarin Banaji were curious. When we say someone is gifted, does it matter whether their talent is the result of hard work or natural ability? Would we see Leopold and Rudolf Blaschka differently if their skill and passion was not in their blood? In an experiment, the scientists asked more than a hundred musical experts whether innate talent or hard work was the more important factor when it came to musical ability. The experts said no contest what matters is hard work hours of practice. But when the musical experts were asked to compare two pieces of music one of which featured a pianist who was said to work very hard at her craft, and another from a musician
这两位研究人员，Chihay Jang Sai 和 Mazarin Banaji 很好奇。当我们说某人天赋异禀时，他们的才能究竟是源于努力工作还是天生能力，这重要吗？如果利奥波德和鲁道夫·布拉斯奇卡的天赋与热情并没有融入他们的血液，我们还会以不同的眼光看待他们吗？在一项实验中，科学家们询问了一百多位音乐专家，在音乐能力方面，先天才能和刻苦努力究竟哪个更重要。专家们异口同声地说，毫无疑问，最重要的是刻苦努力和数小时的练习。但是，当音乐专家们被要求比较两首曲子时——其中一首的演奏者被告知在艺术创作上付出了极大的努力，而另一首则来自一位
who was just naturally gifted, the experts gravitated to the piece of music, said to come from the performer who was naturally gifted. They thought her music was more beautiful. In truth, both the performances that the experts heard were by the same pianist, but the music seemed more impressive when it came from someone who was described as a natural talent rather than someone who was described as a striver. Today, we explore our love affair with brilliance that's in the blood, and we examine how these beliefs shape the organizations where we work and study and play. The Genius Trap, this week on Hidden Brain.
仅仅是天生有天赋的音乐家——专家们更青睐那首据称来自天生才华横溢的演奏者的曲子。他们认为她的音乐更美。事实上，专家们听到的这两段表演都是由同一位钢琴家演奏的，但当音乐被描述为来自一个具有天赋的人，而不是一个奋斗者时，它似乎就更令人印象深刻。今天，我们探讨我们对流淌在血液中的卓越才华的迷恋，并审视这些信念如何塑造了我们工作、学习和玩耍的组织。“天才陷阱”，本周《隐藏的大脑》。
Many episodes of this program explore the gaps between our perception and reality. What is true for individuals is also true for organizations. Schools, nonprofits, and companies want to encourage excellence and spur success. But what they think they are saying to encourage those things is often not what's heard. At Indiana University Bloomington, psychologist Mary Murphy studies how one set of beliefs
本节目的许多期节目都在探讨我们的感知与现实之间的差距。对个人而言是如此，对组织而言也是如此。学校、非营利组织和公司都希望鼓励卓越并促进成功。但是，他们以为自己为了鼓励这些目标而说的话，往往并不是人们所听到的。在印第安纳大学布卢明顿分校，心理学家玛丽·墨菲（Mary Murphy）研究了一套信念是如何
has come to exert a powerful hold on organizations around the world. She explores how the set of beliefs can work at cross purposes with what many organizations want to accomplish. The mismatch has profound effects for institutions and the millions of people who live, work, and study in them.
对世界各地的组织产生强大影响的。她探讨了这套信念如何会与许多组织想要实现的目标产生背离。这种不匹配对机构以及生活、工作和学习其中的数百万人都产生了深远的影响。
Mary Murphy, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It is such a pleasure to be here with you. Mary, when you first arrived at Stanford University to go to graduate school, you picked up on something that many people at the school call the Stanford Duck Syndrome. Describe the syndrome for me, Mary.
玛丽·墨菲，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能和你在一起。玛丽，当你刚到斯坦福大学读研究生时，你注意到了一种许多学校里的人称之为“斯坦福鸭子综合征”的现象。玛丽，请为我描述一下这种综合征。
Yes, this is the idea that the most successful people at this elite high-pressure institution, those people who can look like ducks, who can kind of glide gracefully across the water, any kind of hardship or struggle they might have, simply rolls off your back. But if you look right beneath the surface, you see that people are kicking like crazy to keep up. And I could see this among undergrads. I would see that around them, like lounging in the student union, listening to music as if people didn't have a care in the world.
是的，这种观点认为，在这个精英云集、压力巨大的机构里，最成功的人就像鸭子一样，能够优雅地在水面上滑行，他们可能遇到的任何艰难险阻，都能轻松化解。但如果你仔细观察水面之下，就会发现人们为了跟上进度而在拼命划水。我能在本科生身上看到这一点。我看到他们周围的人，比如在学生会休息、听音乐，好像对世界上的烦恼毫不在意。
No one seemed to have to try hard in order to do well in this environment. But when I talked to my undergrads in my lab, I noticed that students were really paying a high price to embody this cultural value of effortless genius, right? They were exhausted, they had a lot of anxiety and stress trying to keep up. And I think that this syndrome, this Stanford Duck Syndrome, really came from this belief that effort and ability
在这个环境中，似乎没有人需要付出很大努力就能表现得很好。但是，当我与实验室的本科生交谈时，我注意到学生们为了体现这种毫不费力的天才文化，确实付出了高昂的代价，对吧？他们筋疲力尽，为了跟上进度而焦虑和压力巨大。我认为这种综合征，即斯坦福鸭子综合征，实际上源于这样一种信念：努力和能力
are negatively correlated. That if you have to try hard, that it means that maybe you don't have natural ability or skill to be there. So some years later, you found yourself at your first job at Indiana University, and you discovered that the school had a procedure to distribute merit raises to professors.
呈负相关。如果你必须付出艰苦的努力，那就意味着你可能没有在这里的天生能力或技能。所以几年后，你在印第安纳大学迎来了第一份工作，你发现学校有一个向教授发放绩效加薪的程序。
It involved a certain letter that got dropped in your mailbox. What was it like to receive this letter? Yes, a department merit review committee would review every faculty member's, what we call an APR. It's like a annual productivity report. And it has things like how many papers we wrote,
这涉及到一封投进你邮箱的特定信件。收到这封信是什么感觉？是的，系里的绩效评议委员会会审查每一位教职员工的材料，我们称之为APR（年度生产力报告）。它就像是一份年度成果报告。里面记录了诸如我们写了多少篇论文、
how many students we advise, how many grants we get. And what they would do is that they would rank and rate each individual professor. And then, to my horror, I learned that each faculty member would then get a letter in their mailbox showing every person's rank from the highest to the lowest. And your personal position would be brightly highlighted in yellow.
我们指导了多少名学生、我们获得了多少经费等内容。他们会做的是对每位教授进行排名和评级。然后，令我惊恐的是，我得知每位教职员工的邮箱里都会收到一封信，上面列出了从最高到最低的每个人的排名。而你个人的名次会被用醒目的黄色高亮显示。
And I have to say that this day, the day that the letters would arrive in everybody's mailbox, was the day of the year that a lot of our faculty simply dreaded. Music Mary soon noticed that it wasn't just the professors who were being rated in this manner. I was walking by a really large auditorium, our large teaching auditorium, and I noticed several sheets of paper taped on the wall outside of the entrance to that auditorium. And when I went to look more closely, I saw that these papers contained the grades of all students that were enrolled in our introductory
我必须说，这一天——信件送到每个人邮箱里的那一天——是许多教职员工最感到恐惧的一天。音乐玛丽很快注意到，不仅仅是教授们在以这种方式被评级。我走过一个非常大的礼堂，我们的大型阶梯教室，我注意到礼堂入口外面的墙上贴了好几张纸。当我走近仔细看时，我看到这些纸上写着所有选修我们初级
psychology class and they went from highest to lowest and What I noticed was that as the students were streaming by different students took different strategies, right? Some did like a wide art to avoid these papers on the wall Some people gathered around running their fingers down the list trying to look for their ID Hoping to find it on the first or second page and not on the sixth or seventh page. And I just think that this shows how these regular routines and practices can really stoke interpersonal competition, make you feel as though, you know, your learning and your productivity is really going to depend on how you do relative to others. So Mary, the same approach to performance
心理学课程的学生的成绩，从高到低排列。我注意到的是，当学生们从旁边涌过时，不同的学生采取了不同的策略，对吧？有些人绕了很大一个圈来避开墙上的这些纸，有些人则聚集在一起，手指顺着名单往下划，试图寻找自己的学号，希望能在一两页上找到，而不是在第六或第七页。我只是觉得这表明了这些常规的日常惯例和做法如何能够真正激起人际竞争，让你觉得，你的学习和生产力确实取决于你相对于他人的表现。所以，玛丽，当你刚来到印第安纳州时看到的这种对绩效的相同态度
that you saw when you first came to Indiana was also showing up in the corporate world. The idea of stack ranking, as it's called, was popularized at General Electric in the 1980s. Tell me the story of stack ranking in Jack Welsh. Stack ranking is a performance evaluation practice that's pretty common in many organizations. This practice is colloquially called rank and yank.
也出现在了企业界。所谓的分级考核（stack ranking）理念在20世纪80年代由通用电气公司（General Electric）推广开来。请跟我讲讲分级考核和杰克·韦尔奇（Jack Welch）的故事。分级考核是一种在许多组织中相当普遍的绩效评估做法。这种做法在通俗中被称为“排名并解雇”（rank and yank）。
And it was made popular in the early 80s by Jack Welsh, who was at that point CEO of GE. And at GE, what they did was they created three different tiers, employees in the top 20%, those in the middle 70%, and those in the bottom 10%, who are more likely to be let go. In an article published in 2013, Jack Welsh said, "'Yes, I realize that some believe the bell curve aspect of differentiation is cruel. That always strikes me as odd.
它在80年代初由时任通用电气首席执行官的杰克·韦尔奇推广开来。在通用电气，他们的做法是创建三个不同的层级：前20%的员工、中间70%的员工，以及最底层的10%的员工（他们更有可能被解雇）。在2013年发表的一篇文章中，杰克·韦尔奇说：“是的，我意识到有些人认为差异化的钟形曲线方面很残酷。这总是让我觉得奇怪。
We grade children in school, often as young as 9 or 10, and no one calls that cruel. But somehow adults can't take it? Explain that one to me. Stack ranking has spread to many other firms since Jack Welch and GE practiced it 40 years ago. Mary says that includes the co-working company, WeWork. The company WeWork adopted some of this stack ranking and they would let go up to 20% of their workforce annually.
我们在学校给孩子们打分，通常小至9岁或10岁，没有人称之为残酷。但不知何故，成年人就承受不了吗？给我解释一下这个。”自杰克·韦尔奇和通用电气在40年前实行分级考核以来，这种方法已经传播到了许多其他公司。玛丽说，这其中就包括联合办公公司 WeWork。WeWork 公司采纳了部分这种分级考核制度，他们每年会解雇高达20%的员工。
And in WeWork, these were called infamously genocides because it would refer to the attorney Jennifer Barrett who was in charge of all of these layoffs. And what's important to know about stack ranking is that people say well it's okay for the 80% who's gonna be left you know in the organization. But I have to say that being left inside of an organization is not gonna be a walk in the park, right? We know that it breeds competition within each organization and it creates a lot of confusion for employees, right? Should we team? Should we compete? Which can breed a lot of cynicism and distrust.
在 WeWork，这些被称为臭名昭著的“大屠杀”，因为这指的是负责所有这些裁员的律师珍妮弗·巴雷特（Jennifer Barrett）。关于分级考核，重要的是要知道，人们会说，对于留在组织里的那80%的人来说，这没问题。但我必须说，留在组织内部也并非易事，对吧？我们知道，这会在每个组织内部滋生竞争，并给员工带来很多困惑，对吧？我们应该合作吗？我们应该竞争吗？这会滋生很多玩世不恭的态度和不信任感。
So it doesn't take a genius to notice that people respond to the incentives around them. If you tell people that the bottom 20% are going to be fired, the goal might be to get everyone to focus on excellence, but in practice, it gets everyone to focus on each other. So the people at the top of the rankings, they don't want to be displaced. And the people who are lower in the rankings just want to make sure that there's someone else who does worse than them. Absolutely. There's this constant fear of a loss of status, right? Of falling below that line. And those in the top tier are going to be forced to defend their position, right? They're less likely to share resources, to help their colleagues for fear that they're going to be overtaken in the rankings. And they're going to dedicate more energy to watching each other, keeping an eye on their competition,
因此，不用天才也能看出，人们会对周围的激励措施做出反应。如果你告诉人们最底层的20%将被解雇，其目标可能是让每个人都专注于卓越，但在实践中，它让每个人都专注于彼此。因此，排名靠前的人不想被取代。而排名靠后的人只想确保有别人的表现比他们更差。绝对是这样。人们对失去地位有着持续的恐惧，对吧？害怕跌过那条线。而处于顶层的人将被迫捍卫他们的地位，对吧？他们不太愿意分享资源，也不太愿意帮助同事，因为担心自己在排名中被超越。他们会投入更多精力去互相监视，关注竞争对手，
instead of focusing on how and where they can keep growing. Hmm. You know, there's the old joke about the two people who see a tiger. The first one starts lacing up his shoes and the second one says, you're not going to outrun a tiger. And the first person says, I'm not trying to outrun the tiger, I'm just trying to outrun you. Now, stack ranking also has found its way into many schools and not just colleges and universities, but even primary schools. The psychologist Carol Dweck has stories of stack ranking, or its equivalent, in elementary
而不是专注于他们如何以及在哪里可以继续成长。嗯。你知道，有个关于两个人的老笑话，他们看到了一只老虎。第一个人开始系鞋带，第二个人说：“你跑不过老虎的。”第一个人说：“我不是要跑过老虎，我只是要跑过你。”现在，分级考核也进入了许多学校，不仅是高校，甚至还有小学。心理学家卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）就讲述了小学里存在分级考核或其同等形式的故事。
school. She shared with me the story of growing up in her elementary school classroom, where back in the day in her class, they would seat students in order of their IQ score. So students who were the highest on the IQ score were always seated in front. And those who scored lowest, well, they were placed all the way in the back, right? And they would retake these exams
她与我分享了她在小学教室里长大的故事，在那个时代，她的班级里，他们会根据学生的智商分数来安排座位。因此，智商分数最高的学生总是坐在前面。而那些得分最低的人，嗯，他们被安排在最后面，对吧？他们会重新参加这些考试，
and then they'd get reshuffled based on how they performed on these exams. So there was always this threat of losing that status of being the good student and the smart student in this environment. So, Mary, you say that there is an underlying set of beliefs, a mindset in all of these examples that we've discussed. You call it a culture of genius.
然后根据他们在这些考试中的表现重新洗牌。因此，在这个环境中，总是存在着失去“好学生”和“聪明学生”这种地位的威胁。所以，玛丽，你说在我们讨论的所有这些例子中，都存在着一组潜在的信念，一种思维模式。你称之为“天才文化”。
What does this term mean? In a culture of genius, as I call it, the focus is really on star performers and the belief that these people are inherently more capable and superior due to innate intelligence, ability, skills, things that just come naturally. Effortless and perfect performance, right,
这个术语是什么意思？正如我所称的那样，在天才文化中，重点真正放在明星员工身上，并且人们相信这些人由于天生的智力、能力、技能以及那些自然而然产生的东西，天生就更有能力、更优越。毫不费力和完美的表现，对吧，
is the goal in a culture of genius. And so we look for people and we look for individuals who are going to embody that culture of genius, who are the stars, and how do we get more of those individuals into our organization, onto our team, so that we can build even more this culture of genius. And so when we have this culture of genius, whether that's at an individual level or at a collective level, what that basically says is some people know how to swing a baseball bat.
就是天才文化的目标。因此，我们寻找那些将体现天才文化、成为明星的人和个人，我们如何将更多这样的个人引入我们的组织、我们的团队，以便我们能够建立更多的这种天才文化。因此，当我们拥有这种天才文化时，无论是在个人层面还是在集体层面，这基本上说明的是：有些人知道如何挥舞棒球棒。
Some people know how to play chess. Some people know how to do math. Those are the people who are going to be good at doing those things. Absolutely. The culture of genius wants genius, and they believe in genius very strongly. And so they're going to look for people who really seem
有些人知道如何下棋。有些人知道如何做数学题。这些人就是那些擅长做这些事情的人。绝对是这样的。天才文化渴望天才，他们对天才坚信不疑。因此，他们会寻找那些似乎真正拥有这些天生才能和天赋的人，他们会努力寻找那些似乎真正拥有这些天生才能和天赋的人，并试图招募和留住这些个人。这些人将是被提升、被晋升、被投入资金的对象，他们是天才文化的根源及其对个人和组织的影响。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦达坦姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦达坦姆。
to have these innate talents and gifts, and they're going to try for people who really seem to have these innate talents and gifts, and they're going to try to recruit and retain those individuals. Those are going to be the individuals that are lifted up and that are promoted and that are going to be invested in origins of the culture of genius and its effect on people and organizations. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
拥有这些与生俱来的天赋和才能，他们会寻找那些真正似乎具备这些与生俱来天赋和才能的人，并试图招募和留住这些个人。这些人将是被提拔、被晋升、并将获得投资的对象，这正是天才文化的发端及其对个人和组织的影响。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
Have you ever been in a school or organization where you felt that people wrote you off, where no one believed in you, and people communicated that you didn't belong. If this has happened to you, you know it doesn't feel good. But more than the problem of how it feels, something profound happens in our minds when we come to believe that there is a ceiling on what we can accomplish, what we can learn, and what we can do. At Indiana University Bloomington, Mary Murphy studies the effects of these mental ceilings on organizations and the people who live and work inside them. Mary, the Stanford psychologist Carol Dweck was your mentor and she developed an idea
你是否曾身处一所学校或组织中，让你觉得人们对你写下休止符，没有人相信你，大家都在传递一种你并不属于这里的信号。如果这曾发生在你的身上，你知道这感觉并不好。但比这种感觉更成问题的是，当我们开始相信我们所能取得的成就、我们所能学习的以及我们所能做的事情存在上限时，我们的心灵就会发生深刻的变化。在印第安纳大学布卢明顿分校，玛丽·墨菲研究了这些思维上限对组织以及生活和工作在其中的人们的影响。玛丽，斯坦福大学的心理学家卡罗尔·德韦克是你的导师，她提出了一个被称为成长型思维的概念。
known as growth mindset. Could you explain what a growth mindset is as well as its opposite, a fixed mindset? Yes, the growth mindset is oftentimes characterized as a belief that talent and ability and performance, all of these skills, they're potentials that we can grow with the right support, asking for help, trying new strategies, and the opposite of the growth mindset is the fixed mindset. And this is the belief that talent, ability, skills,
你能解释一下什么是成长型思维以及它的对立面——固定型思维吗？是的，成长型思维通常被描述为这样一种信念：天赋、能力和绩效，所有这些技能，都是我们可以通过适当的支持、寻求帮助、尝试新策略来不断成长的潜力。而成长型思维的对立面则是固定型思维。这是一种信念：天赋、能力、技能，
these are things that are fixed. They're like traits. You either have them or you don't. And so it's impossible to significantly grow, change, or develop those skills and abilities. And so the point of that fixed mindset is to figure out what you're good at and then just do those things.
这些都是固定的东西。它们就像是特质。要么你有，要么你没有。因此，大幅度成长、改变或发展这些技能和能力是不可能的。所以，固定型思维的要点就是弄清楚你擅长什么，然后只做那些事情。
I mean, in some ways this seems to be partly about the age old debate between nature and nurture. Is ability merely something that's inside of us or is it something that we can learn and cultivate? Growth mindset seems to emphasize the role of effort and hard work and perseverance in developing skills, whereas a fixed mindset might emphasize innate ability, innate talent. Yes, that's the big difference between the fixed mindset and the growth mindset.
我的意思是，在某些方面，这似乎部分关于先天与后天之间古老的辩论。能力仅仅是我们内在的东西，还是我们可以学习和培养的东西？成长型思维似乎强调了努力、刻苦和坚持在培养技能方面的作用，而固定型思维则可能强调先天能力、先天天赋。是的，这就是固定型思维和成长型思维之间的巨大区别。
How does a culture of genius fit with these two ideas? In some ways, it seems to be connected to what you just described as the fixed mindset. For about 25 to 30 years, this idea of the fixed mindset and the growth mindset were traditionally studied as individual differences. What's your belief, Shankar, and what's my belief, and how does that influence our motivation, our engagement, the way we respond to challenges, whether we hide mistakes or whether we relish mistakes and learn from them. And the insight I had, oh, maybe about 12, 13 years ago now, was that the fixed-in-growth mindset isn't just inside our minds.
天才文化如何与这两个概念契合？在某些方面，它似乎与你刚才描述的固定型思维有关。在大约25到30年的时间里，固定型思维和成长型思维这两个概念传统上被作为个体差异来研究。尚卡尔，你的信念是什么，我的信念是什么，这如何影响我们的动力、我们的投入、我们应对挑战的方式，是我们隐藏错误还是享受错误并从中吸取教训。而我大约在12、13年前得到的启发是，固定型思维和成长型思维不仅存在于我们的头脑中。
It's not just a belief that you or I have, that it actually can be a feature of an environment. It can be a feature of teams, of groups, of divisions, of organizations. It can be a feature of families. Anytime two or more people are together, we can have a mindset culture that really communicates whether we believe as a group that intelligence, skills, and ability are fixed. You either have them or you don't, or it's possible to grow, develop and learn new skills, intelligence, ability and other aspects of ourselves.
它不仅是你我所拥有的信念，它实际上还可以是环境的一个特征。它可以是团队、群体、部门、组织的一个特征。它可以是家庭的一个特征。只要有两个或更多的人在一起，我们就可以拥有一种思维模式文化，它真正传达的是，作为一个群体，我们是否相信智力、技能和能力是固定的。要么你有，要么你没有，或者有可能成长、发展和学习新的技能、智力、能力以及我们自己的其他方面。
Now a focus on brilliance can seem like a good thing, you know, what can be wrong with being brilliant, but the philosopher Sarah Jane Leslie and the psychologist Andre Simpion once analyzed how much people in different fields believe that success is about innate ability. Can you tell me what they found, Mary? This is one of my favorite studies. What this group of researchers did was survey more than 1,800 faculty, postdocs, and graduate students across 30 different disciplines at universities across the United States. And then at the same time, they gathered data from the National Science Foundation about the percentage of women and students of color who went to pursue PhDs in each one of these disciplines.
现在，对卓越的关注似乎是一件好事，你知道，追求卓越有什么错呢，但是哲学家萨拉·简·莱斯利（Sarah Jane Leslie）和心理学家安德烈·辛皮翁（Andre Simpion）曾经分析过不同领域的人在多大程度上相信成功取决于先天能力。玛丽，你能告诉我他们发现了什么吗？这是我最喜欢的研究之一。这组研究人员的做法是，对美国各地大学中30个不同学科的1800多名教职员工、博士后和研究生进行了调查。然后与此同时，他们从国家科学基金会收集了关于追求这些学科博士学位的女性和有色人种学生比例的数据。
And what they found in that survey of faculty, postdocs, and graduate students was that there seemed to be some consensus around different fields. Some fields really believed that what it took to be successful in that field required brilliance and genius for success, whereas other fields were thought to require more empathy or hard work or persistence through challenges. And what they found was that math, physics, economics, some parts of music, music composition in particular, were thought to require brilliance.
他们在对教职员工、博士后和研究生的调查中发现，不同领域之间似乎存在某种共识。有些领域真的认为，要在该领域取得成功，需要聪慧和天才才能成功，而其他领域则被认为需要更多的同理心、刻苦或在挑战中坚持不懈。他们发现的是，数学、物理、经济学、音乐的某些部分，特别是音乐创作，被认为需要聪慧。
And others that were thought to have other aspects that were important for success, things like empathy and hard work, were other of the social sciences, psychology, many of the humanities-based work, although philosophy was one of those that was really thought to require brilliance and genius for success. And what they found was that when those fields were thought to require more genius and brilliance for success, the less number of women and people of color were included in those disciplines as pursuing PhDs. Hmm. So in your own work with these two researchers, you've explored why messages about brilliance
而其他被认为具有对成功很重要的其他方面的领域——诸如同理心和刻苦努力等事情——则是其他社会科学、心理学、许多基于人文学科的工作，尽管哲学是被真正认为需要聪慧和天才才能成功的学科之一。他们发现的是，当这些领域被认为需要更多天才和聪慧才能成功时，女性和有色人种作为追求博士学位的人加入这些学科的人数就越少。嗯。因此，在你与这两位研究人员的共同工作中，你探讨了为什么关于聪慧的信息
might undermine women's interest in certain fields. Why does this happen, Mary? Yeah, one of the biggest problems that we see with cultures of genius is that we have a specific prototype of who is a genius. We have a prototype of who's going to be successful in these different environments. And what we've seen across decades of our work now is that while these prototypes can vary by industry, we find that most people, when you put in the word genius into Google images, the images that come to mind there are people like Albert Einstein, Thomas Edison,
可能会削弱女性对某些领域的兴趣。为什么会这样，玛丽？是的，我们在天才文化中看到的最大问题之一，就是我们对谁是天才有一个特定的原型。我们对谁能在这些不同的环境中取得成功有一个原型。我们在几十年的工作中看到的是，虽然这些原型可能因行业而异，但我们发现大多数人，当你在谷歌图片中输入“天才”这个词时，脑海中浮现的图片都是阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦、托马斯·爱迪生、
Elon Musk, Bill Gates, right? This is a pretty homogenous group. And what we see is that when we're in these cultures of genius, we look for people who are gonna match our genius prototypes. And these are gonna be the people who we seek out, who we hire, and who we promote in different organizations. And it's really why cultures of genius often overlook and miss out
埃隆·马斯克、比尔·盖茨这样的人，对吧？这是一个相当同质化的群体。我们看到的是，当我们处于这些天才文化中时，我们会寻找那些符合我们天才原型的人。这些人就是我们在各个组织中寻找、雇用和晋升的人。这正是为什么天才文化经常忽视并错过
on identifying and recruiting people from diverse groups. And it's why in our own work, we started to see that anytime these messages really suggest that these areas require brilliance, it undermines women's interest because they expect to be stereotyped more in these environments as not being innately gifted, having those genius qualities, right? They don't really match this prototype and they know it and they think they're going to be judged for it in these environments. You know, I think some people might say, you say, isn't it true that some people in some fields, like mathematics,
识别和招募来自不同群体的的原因。这也是为什么在我们自己的工作中，我们开始看到，每当这些消息真正暗示这些领域需要聪慧时，它就会削弱女性的兴趣，因为她们预计自己在这些环境中会被更多地贴上刻板标签，认为她们不具备天生才能、不具备那些天才品质，对吧？她们并不真正符合这个原型，她们心知肚明，并且认为她们在这些环境中会因此受到评判。你知道，我想有些人可能会说，你会说，难道不是真的吗，某些领域中的某些人，比如数学，
for example, are really brilliant and in some ways it comes really easy to them that they are able to pick up on things very quickly? I think that this is a bit of a myth, more than what we want to acknowledge in a society that really values independence and natural talent and ability, right? I think there's many, many cases where we have told ourselves the story of genius, of an individual, right? The apple just falls on the head and suddenly you have this brilliant idea and this equation comes to mind, right?
例如，真的很聪明，在某些方面事情对他们来说确实轻而易举，他们能够非常快地掌握事物？我认为这有点像是个神话，比起我们在一个真正重视独立性、自然天赋和能力的社会中所愿意承认的还要多，对吧？我认为有很多很多情况下，我们给自己讲过关于天才、关于某个个人的故事，对吧？苹果砸在头上，突然你就有了一个 brilhant 的想法，这个方程浮现在脑海里，对吧？
We know these stories. And, but the truth is, like in Thomas Edison's case, for example, right? We like to hold him up as this genius. But of course, he had teams and teams and teams of people working for him and with him to test many, many iterations of his technologies, right? And there were many more failures than there were successes. And so we really don't give enough space for the way that
我们都知道这些故事。但是事实是，比如在托马斯·爱迪生的例子中，对吧？我们喜欢把他当成这个天才来崇拜。但当然，他拥有团队、团队、团队的人为他工作，与他一起测试他的技术的许多许多迭代，对吧？失败的次数远远多于成功的次数。因此，我们确实没有为以下方式留出足够的空间：
talent and ability is actually created and how we become the people we do over time. Is there any space in your vision and philosophy, Mary, for innate differences between people? Absolutely. I do think that there's probably some innate characteristics, some personality traits, some inclination towards different kinds of interests that can come when people are born and certainly when people are socialized by their parents, by their teachers, and by important people in their environment. But the truth is that we're all going to develop, right?
天赋和能力实际上是如何创造的，以及我们如何随着时间的推移成为今天的我们。玛丽，在你的愿景和哲学中，是否存在关于人与人之间先天差异的空间？绝对存在。我确实认为，当人们出生时，肯定存在一些先天特征、一些人格特质、对不同类型兴趣的某种倾向，当然，当人们受到父母、老师和环境中重要人物的社会化影响时也是如此。但事实是，我们都会成长，对吧？
Nobody is born knowing how to read out of the womb. No one is born, right, understanding how to solve important math equations. I do think that people have different kinds of starting places and interests. The question is, I think, whether you want people to have a growth mindset about that inclination, or do you want them to have a fixed mindset and make it real? I think what I'm hearing you say is that, you know, it's not that there are no innate differences between people, but that the more we focus on innate differences that we cannot control, the less we'll be able to focus on the things that we can control. So to pick a completely different domain, you know, I'm a keen amateur swimmer.
没有人一生下来就会阅读。没有人一生下来就懂得如何解开重要的数学方程。我确实认为人们有不同类型的起点和兴趣。问题在于，我认为，你是希望人们对这种倾向抱有成长型思维，还是希望他们抱有固定型思维并使其成为现实？我想我听到你所说的是，你知道，并不是人与人之间没有先天差异，而是我们越是专注于我们无法控制的先天差异，我们就越无法专注于我们能够控制的事情。因此，挑选一个完全不同的领域，你知道，我是一个狂热的业余游泳爱好者。
You're not saying that if I really worked at it, I could out swim Katie Ledecky, but you are saying that to the extent I believe that Katie Ledecky's ability is purely innate and not the result of tons of hard work, it makes it less likely that I'll put in the work to become the best swimmer I can be. That's absolutely correct. So well said. In your surveys of college students, Mary, you find that they often get messages, usually implicitly but often explicitly, that some people have what it takes and others do not. What are some of the things that students have reported to you? So some of the things, the infamous things that people will say, say at the start of
你并不是说如果我真正努力了，我就能游得过凯蒂·莱德基（Katie Ledecky），但你是说，就我相信凯蒂·莱德基的能力纯粹是天生的，而不是大量刻苦努力的结果而言，这让我更有可能不会付出努力去成为我所能成为的最佳游泳运动员。完全正确。说得太好了。玛丽，在对大学生的调查中，你发现他们经常接到信息，通常是隐式的但往往是显式的，即有些人具备成功所需的条件，而另一些人则没有。学生向你报告的一些事情是什么？因此，有些事情，人们会说的那些臭名昭著的话，比如在
a difficult math class or a very large chemistry 400 person auditorium class. They might say, look to your left, look to your right, only one of you is gonna be here at the end of the semester, right? I couldn't think of anything more zero sum than that. My professor said 30% of you will fail, 20% of you are gonna get Ds at the end of the term. It happens every year and it will happen this year to you.
一门困难的数学课或一个拥有400名学生的大型化学阶梯教室的第一节课上。他们可能会说：“看看你的左边，看看你的右边，到学期末时你们中只有一个人会留在这里，”对吧？我想不出比这更零和博弈的事情了。我的教授说：“你们中有30%的人会挂科，你们中有20%的人在学期末会得D。每年都会发生，今年也会发生在你身上。”
Right, a neuroscience professor who says, if students aren't confident about your ability, of the term, it happens every year and it will happen this year to you. Right? A neuroscience professor who says, if students aren't confident about your ability, you should consider transferring to another instructor. Right? A chemistry professor who says, if you don't get it early and quickly, you just don't belong in this class. So you found that students who perceive that their professor endorses a fixed mindset experience a number of things,
没错，一位神经科学教授说：“如果学生对你们的能力没有信心，期末……每年都会发生，今年也会发生在你身上。”没错。一位化学教授说：“如果你不能早点并且迅速地掌握它，你就不属于这个班。”所以你发现，那些察觉到自己的教授支持固定型思维的学生会经历很多事情，
including feelings of being imposter. So even if they do well, they tell themselves, you know, it can't be true because I'm not a genius. That's right. We do find over and over that the students who see that their instructor endorses this belief that only some students have it and some students don't. Look to your left, look to your right.
包括冒名顶替综合征的感觉。所以即使他们做得很好，他们也会告诉自己，你知道，这不可能是真的，因为我不是天才。没错。我们一次又一次地发现，那些看到自己的教授认同“只有少数学生具备天赋，而其他学生则没有”这一信念的学生。看看你的左边，看看你的右边。
Only one of you is gonna be here at the end of the term. If they find themselves struggling, if they find themselves making mistakes, if they find themselves not getting things effortlessly and perfectly right immediately in the class, they can often feel as though they're an imposter in that classroom. And that can really set them back in terms of seeking help, asking questions, finding a study group to work with, and all of the things that we know actually contribute to student success.
到学期末时你们中只有一个人会留在这里。如果他们发现自己苦苦挣扎，如果他们发现自己犯了错误，如果他们发现自己无法在课堂上立刻毫不费力、完美地掌握东西，他们往往会觉得自己是那个课堂上的冒名顶替者。这在寻求帮助、提问、寻找学习小组以及我们知道实际上有助于学生成功的所有事情方面，确实会让他们倒退。
One of your studies examined differences between men and women to signals that their company had a fixed mindset or a growth mindset. Can you tell me what you found? This was a set of studies that I conducted with my former PhD student, Kathy Emerson. What we were really looking at was the question of why women remain underrepresented in leadership positions around corporate America, right? And our theory was that women are going to be really vigilant to cues in the environment
你的其中一项研究检验了男女之间对公司表现出固定型思维或成长型思维信号的反应差异。你能告诉我你发现了什么吗？这是一组我和前博士生凯茜·爱默生（Kathy Emerson）一起进行的研究。我们真正关注的问题是：为什么女性在企业界的高层职位中仍然代表性不足，对吧？我们的理论是，女性会对环境中的线索保持高度警惕，
that signal to them whether they're valued and respected or whether or not they're going to be devalued and disrespected. And so what we did in this study was men and women looked at company mission statements and websites that contained either fixed or growth mindset messaging. And what we found across these three different experiments and studies was that women more than men trusted that fixed-minded company less than the growth-minded company.
这些线索向她们发出信号，表明她们是受到重视和尊重，还是会被贬低和不尊重。因此，在这项研究中，我们让男女员工查看了包含固定型或成长型思维信息的公司使命声明和网站。我们在三个不同的实验和研究中发现，女性比男性对固定型思维公司的信任度低于成长型思维公司。
And then we also found that the mistrust was actually driven by women's expectations that they were going to be negatively stereotyped by that company's management. They know what the prototype for brilliance and genius is in business, and they thought that the management and the leaders in that organization would really compare them to that prototype and find them lacking. And then finally, in our last study, we found that mistrust of these companies actually led women to disengage more following negative feedback from that company. Yeah.
然后我们还发现，不信任实际上是由女性的期望驱动的——即她们预计自己会被该公司管理层给予负面刻板印象。她们知道商业中聪慧和天才的原型是什么，并且她们认为该组织的管理层和领导者会将她们与那个原型进行比较，并发现她们有所欠缺。最后，在我们的最后一项研究中，我们发现对这些公司的这种不信任实际上导致女性在收到该公司的负面反馈后更多地选择脱离。是的。
Another effect of a culture of genius is that it can cause people to decline new opportunities. Why might this be, Mary? Yes, we have found this over and over in our work in terms of thinking about engagement and interest. We did these studies across many different institutions and many different contexts. And what we found was that when students perceive their instructor to endorse more fixed mindset
天才文化的另一个影响是，它会导致人们拒绝新的机会。玛丽，这可能是为什么？是的，我们在关于投入和兴趣的思考中，在我们的工作中一次又一次地发现了这一点。我们在许多不同的机构和不同的背景下进行了这些研究。我们发现，当学生感知到他们的教授认同更多的固定型思维
beliefs when they feel as though they're in this culture of genius, we find that these cultures of genius lower students' interests not just in this particular chemistry class or that particular biology class, but it actually also lowers interest in the professor's discipline more generally. So now I'm less likely after finishing this class to take Chem 201 or Biology 201, and I start to close doors to different kinds of opportunities and paths myself because I simply notice I'm feeling this way in the classroom. Now cultures of genius can also lead to high stakes disasters because of course when you anoint someone a genius you stop being able to question if they could be wrong.
信念时——当他们觉得身处这种天才文化中时——我们发现这些天才文化不仅会降低学生对这个特定化学课或那个特定生物课的兴趣，实际上还会更广泛地降低学生对教授所在学科的兴趣。因此，上完这门课后，我不太可能再去选修化学201或生物201，我开始自己关闭通往不同类型机会和路径的大门，因为我只是注意到我在课堂上有这种感觉。现在，天才文化也可能导致高风险的灾难，因为当然，当你将某人封为天才时，你就无法再质疑他们是否会犯错。
Many listeners on this show are going to be familiar with the story of Elizabeth Holmes and her blood testing company Theranos. But can you briefly describe for others what happened and how it might be connected to this culture of genius? I do think that Elizabeth Holmes serves as a model for the really the extremes of this fixed minded behavior. Holmes set out to really create this device, which maybe not incidentally was dubbed the Edison, right? Another famous genius that would perform hundreds of tests, right? On a very tiny sample of blood. And people were really trying to raise the bell and suggest that maybe this isn't possible or maybe we need a different strategy or this simply isn't working, right?
这个节目的许多听众都会熟悉伊丽莎白·霍姆斯（Elizabeth Holmes）及其血液检测公司 Theranos 的故事。但是你能向其他人简要描述一下发生了什么以及它可能如何与这种天才文化联系在一起吗？我确实认为伊丽莎白·霍姆斯是这种固定型思维行为极端化的一个典范。霍姆斯着手真正创造这种设备，可能并非巧合的是，它被称为“爱迪生”，对吧？另一个著名的天才，它可以在一个非常微小的血液样本上进行数百次测试，对吧？人们真的试图敲响警钟，暗示这可能是不可能的，或者也许我们需要不同的策略，或者这根本行不通，对吧？
But what she did was she would ignore the naysayers and she found individuals who really believed in her, compared her to geniuses that said that she was like Beethoven. And soon she became this darling of the tech world. And she found herself in really high stakes situations where she had to make good on hundreds of millions of dollars in venture capital funding.
但她的做法是忽视唱反调的人，她找到了那些真正信任她的人，将她与天才进行比较，说她就像贝多芬一样。很快，她就成为了科技界的宠儿。她发现自己身处真正高风险的境地，必须兑现数亿美元的风险投资资金。
The problem was that of course the device didn't work. she had to make good on hundreds of millions of dollars in venture capital funding. The problem was that, of course, the device didn't work. And so instead of coming clean and asking her prestigious board members or her mentors for help, she lied to investors and employees, right? She lied to the board and to federal regulators. And also she pushed workers to falsify test results. And workers sent blood samples to regular blood testing labs for analysis and then pretended the samples had been analyzed
问题当然是该设备根本无法工作。她必须兑现数亿美元的风险投资资金。问题当然是该设备根本无法工作。因此，她没有坦白并向她声名显赫的董事会成员或导师寻求帮助，而是对投资者和员工撒谎，对吧？她对董事会和联邦监管机构撒谎。此外，她还敦促员工伪造测试结果。员工将血液样本送到常规血液检测实验室进行分析，然后假装这些样本已经由 Theranos 机器进行了分析。
by the Theranos machines. The solution to the problem seems easy. Just tell students and employees to have a growth mindset. When we come back, why that approach does not always work, and Mary's insight into how to bring about real change. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Mary Murphy is the author of Cultures of Growth, How the New Science of Mindset Can Transform
解决这个问题的办法似乎很简单。只要告诉学生和员工拥有成长型思维即可。当我们回来时，为什么这种方法并不总是奏效，以及玛丽关于如何带来真正改变的见解。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦达坦姆。玛丽·墨菲是《成长文化：思维模式的新科学如何改变个人、团队和组织》（Cultures of Growth, How the New Science of Mindset Can Transform Individuals, Teams, and organizations）一书的作者。她对各类学校、公司和组织为了从学生、员工和公民身上发挥出最好的一面而做过和没有做过的事情很感兴趣。所以玛丽，研究人员一段时间以来一直在试图改变我们在固定型思维中看到的一些消极结果。其中许多干预措施都集中在学生或员工身上，试图让他们看到自己的潜力是可塑的而不是固定的。
Individuals, Teams, and organizations. She's interested in what schools, companies, and organizations of all kinds do and don't do to get the best out of students, employees, and citizens. So Mary, researchers have been trying for a while to change some of the negative outcomes we see with fixed mindsets. Many of these interventions focused on students or employees and tried to get them to see their own potential as malleable rather than fixed.
我想知道你是否能给我介绍一下所探讨的干预措施的类型，以及可以公平地描述为这些干预措施带来的喜忧参半的结果。因此，在过去10到15年中被最常研究的干预措施类型是，向学生或员工展示各种基于科学的材料，这些材料展示了
I'm wondering if you can give me a flavor of the kinds of interventions that have been explored, as well as what can be fairly described as the mixed bag of results that came from these interventions. So the kinds of interventions that had most often been studied in the last 10 to 15 years present students or employees with different kinds of science-based materials that show
个人的大脑能够成长新的连接、创建新的通路、在人们真正处于学习过程中、在人们犯错误时实际产生新的细胞，并真正传达我们的智力、才能和能力如何随着时间的推移而改变：通过努力、在我们遇到困难时尝试新策略、通过寻求帮助和获得他人的支持，它真正试图灌输那种成长型思维。我想说的是，这些直接针对学生或直接针对员工的干预措施一开始取得了很大的成功，但随着它们的增长
individuals, the brain's ability to grow new connections, to create new pathways, to actually generate new cells when people are really in the process of learning, when people are making mistakes and communicating really how our intelligence, talents, and abilities can shift over time by trying hard, by trying new strategies when we get stuck, by seeking help and the support of others, that it really seeks to then instill that growth mindset. And I would say that these direct to student or direct to employee interventions at first had a lot of success, but as they have grown
个体，大脑生长新连接、创造新通路、甚至在人们真正处于学习过程中、在人们犯错并进行沟通时真正生成新细胞的能力，实际上展现了我们的智力、天赋和能力如何通过努力、在遇到瓶颈时尝试新策略、寻求帮助以及他人的支持而随时间发生转变，这确实旨在灌输这种成长型心态。我想说的是，这些直接针对学生或员工的干预措施最初取得了很大成功，但随着它们的不断发展
and as different groups have tried to replicate them, they take different kinds of strategies in that replication. They might try different kinds of outcomes. And we are seeing variability in these results over time, where some studies are replicating these these results over time, where some studies are replicating these effects and in others there's finding challenges in finding effects or as large of effects as some of the original studies had shown. I want to talk a moment, Mary, about how some people have taken this mixed bag of results
随着不同的群体试图复制它们，他们在复制的过程中采用了不同的策略。他们可能会尝试不同种类的结果。随着时间的推移，我们看到了这些结果的变异性，一些研究随着时间的推移复制了这些效果，而在另一些研究中，发现在寻找效果或像最初的一些研究所显示的那样显著的效果时存在挑战。玛丽，我想花一点时间谈谈，有些人是如何看待这堆混合的结果的
and drawn the conclusion that growth mindsets as a whole are not real or that they don't exist or that interventions are completely ineffective. Is that an accurate characterization of the body of research? I don't think that it is. My research and the research of others on this idea of the cultures of growth actually can explain why we see some of this variability in the results. The truth is that our capacity to use our talent and our ability is really gonna depend on the people in the context around us, right? This is a social endeavor, learning and development.
并得出了这样的结论：成长型思维整体上是不真实的，或者它们并不存在，或者干预措施完全无效。这能准确描述这一系列的研究吗？我认为并非如此。我的研究以及其他人对“成长文化”这一理念的研究，实际上可以解释为什么我们会看到结果中存在这种变异性。事实是，我们运用天赋和能力的能力，很大程度上取决于我们周围的人和环境，对吧？学习和发展是一项社会性的工作。
And students and employees can have the strongest growth mindset at the personal level, but if they find themselves in these fixed-minded cultures of genius, they're not gonna be able to use or benefit from that growth mindset. So what I'm hearing you say, Mary, is that when it comes to changing a fixed mindset, it's not enough just to focus on individuals.
学生和员工可以在个人层面拥有最坚强的成长型思维，但如果他们发现自己处于这种固定型思维的天才文化中，他们将无法运用这种成长型思维，也无法从中受益。所以玛丽，我听到你所说的是，当谈到改变固定型思维时，仅仅关注个人是不够的。
You actually have to think about the culture around that individual. And there have been a number of studies now that have looked at this question. In 2021, you and a number of other researchers ran a study that explored why growth mindset interventions sometimes work and sometimes don't work. You were looking at teachers and students. Can you describe what the study did and what you found? This study included a nationally representative sample of more than teachers, and students. Can you describe what the study did and what you found? This study included a nationally representative sample of more than 12,000 students. And what we found in the study was that students who participated in an online program really
你实际上必须考虑该个人周围的文化。现在已经有许多研究探讨了这个问题。2021年，你和许多其他研究人员进行了一项研究，探讨了为什么成长型思维干预有时有效，有时无效。你们当时在研究老师和学生。你能描述一下这项研究是如何进行的以及你们发现了什么吗？这项研究包括了一个由超过12,000名学生组成的全国代表性样本。我们在研究中发现，参与在线项目的学生确实
designed to instill that growth mindset we talked about earlier, we did find overall that they earned higher grades and they were more willing to take on challenges by enrolling in more advanced classes over time. However, we also looked at where this program did not work. And where it didn't help students was when teachers were in their fixed mindsets and when they were engaged in teaching practices consistent with those fixed mindset beliefs, or in other words,
旨在灌输我们之前讨论过的成长型思维，我们确实发现总的来说，他们获得了更高的成绩，并且随着时间推移，他们更愿意通过选修更多的高级课程来接受挑战。然而，我们也研究了该项目不起作用的地方。它对学生没有帮助的情况是，当老师处于固定型思维中，并且当他们从事符合这些固定型思维信念的教学实践时，换句话说，
where they were creating these cultures of genius. And this is why cultures of growth are really crucial for helping us get into, stay in, and then maximize the benefits of our growth mindset. If we have a strong culture of genius around us, there's gonna be very few opportunities for us to actually engage in the process of learning, to make mistakes, to raise our hand and say,
即他们正在创造这些天才文化。这就是为什么成长文化对于帮助我们进入、保持并最大化成长型思维的好处至关重要。如果我们周围有强大的天才文化，我们将极少有机会真正参与学习过程、犯错、举手说：
I don't understand, can you tell me again? We're not gonna feel comfortable really engaging in the behaviors that increase learning and development and growth. So in some ways what we're doing is we're really moving from perhaps the fixed mindset, growth mindset dichotomy to really the idea of a culture of genius and a culture of growth, as sort
我不明白，你能再跟我讲一遍吗？我们将不会感到舒适去真正参与那些能够增加学习、发展和成长的行为。所以在某种程度上，我们所做的实际上是从固定型思维与成长型思维的二分法，真正转向了天才文化和成长文化的理念，有点
of saying this is not just about the individual, it's about the world in which the individual finds herself situated. You once ran a study at a large multinational bank, and you discovered that the mindsets of managers played a very powerful role in how they behaved toward employees and how employees then behave themselves. Tell me about the study. We looked at measuring people's individual mindsets and then we looked at the mindset culture that was being communicated in regular practices and policies at the organization
像是在说，这不仅关乎个人，还关乎个人所处的这个世界。你曾经在一个大型跨国银行进行过研究，你发现经理的心态在他们对待员工的行为以及员工随后的行为中扮演了非常强大的角色。跟我讲讲这项研究吧。我们首先测量了人们的个人心态，然后研究了组织中通过常规实践和政策所传达的心态文化，
and in their routine interactions that managers would have consistently with employees. And what we found was that above and beyond the effects of anyone's personal mindsets on the ground in terms of predicting their performance outcomes and predicting their experiences in the organization, how motivated they were, how satisfied, how much they trusted the organization, how committed to it they were, we found that it was actually that mindset culture as communicated in the way culture is through these policies, practices, norms, and leadership messages. That the way in which managers gave feedback to individuals,
以及经理与员工之间持续进行的日常互动。我们发现，除了任何人地面上的个人心态对预测其绩效结果和预测其在组织中的体验（如他们的积极性如何、满意度如何、他们对组织的信任度有多高、对组织的承诺有多深）的影响之外，我们发现，实际上是这种通过政策、实践、规范和领导者信息等文化传达方式所表达的心态文化。经理向个人提供反馈的方式，
the way that they praised individuals, right? Were they just signaling out individuals who are already seen as high performers and only giving those individuals praise? Were they giving stretch assignments to individuals who are only considered geniuses? Or did they really focus on developing everybody on their team over time? We saw that these kinds of manager policies and practices and the way that they ran their team meetings to really sort of emphasize learning and growth, right, reflect on our mistakes, and then brainstorm together how we're going to address them, versus only talk
他们表扬个人的方式，对吧？他们是否只是挑选那些已经被视为高绩效者的人并只给这些人表扬？他们是否只把挑战性任务分配给被认为是天才的人？还是他们真正专注于随着时间的推移发展团队中的每个人？我们看到，这些经理的政策和实践，以及他们运行团队会议以真正强调学习和成长的方式，对吧？反思我们的错误，然后集思广益讨论我们将如何解决这些问题，而不是只谈论
about the good things that are happening on our team and hide mistakes. That culture is the thing that predicted people's experiences in that organization above and beyond individuals' personal mindsets. So of course organizations and individuals are not either entirely growth mindset, entirely fixed mindset, entirely culture of genius, entirely culture of growth. They reside on a spectrum, but I think what I'm hearing you say is that there are a number of things that
我们团队中正在发生的 好事情并隐瞒错误。这种文化才是预测人们在该组织中体验的因素，它超越了个人自身的成长型思维。因此，当然，组织和个人并非完全是成长型思维、完全是固定型思维、完全是天才文化、完全是成长文化。它们位于一个光谱上，但我认为我听到你所说的是，有许多事情
leaders, managers, and teachers can do to de-emphasize the importance of innate brilliance. And the first might be to simply stop talking about brilliant geniuses. Do you think that might be a first step, Mary? I think that is important. I also think that it can be important to tell stories, real stories, of how brilliance and geniuses developed over time. I don't know if you're familiar, I bet that you are, with Anders Erikson's work, where he sort of followed people in their trajectories of the most talented and brilliant and gifted musician
领导者、经理和老师可以做，来淡化天生聪颖的重要性。而第一步可能就是停止谈论聪明的天才。你认为这可能是第一步吗，玛丽？我认为这很重要。我也认为，讲述关于聪颖和天才如何随时间发展的真实故事也很重要。我不知道你是否熟悉，我敢打赌你肯定熟悉，安德斯·埃里森（Anders Erikson）的工作，他在各种不同的学科中追踪了那些最有才华、最聪明、最有天赋的音乐家、
and basketball player and artist, right, across all these different disciplines. And when you ask and you look at these people's life histories, what you see over and over is and you look at these people's life histories, what you see over and over is that everyone close to them when they were little oftentimes wouldn't have predicted the trajectory that they ultimately found themselves in, right? That these kids were not distinguishable from their peers most of the time. That it actually took development and their parents, teachers and coaches and others really investing time,
篮球运动员和艺术家的发展轨迹。当你去询问并审视这些人的生平历史时，你一次又一次看到的是，在他们小时候，周围的许多人往往无法预测他们最终发现自己的发展轨迹，对吧？这些孩子在大多数时候与同龄人没有什么区别。实际上是需要发展，以及他们的父母、老师、教练和其他人真正投入时间、
energy and resources to help those individuals become who they became. And I think that that kind of story around genius, right, is one that actually can give people the motivation and some of the strategies that actually might be useful to achieve their potential. You told us earlier in this chat, Mary, how your current institution, Indiana University, used to use this ranking system to award merit raises.
精力和资源来帮助这些个人成为他们后来的样子。我认为，围绕天才的这种故事，实际上可以给人以动力和一些策略，这些策略可能有助于他们实现自己的潜力。玛丽，你在这次谈话的早些时候告诉我们，你目前的机构印第安纳大学过去常常使用这种排名系统来发放绩效加薪。
Are those lists still in practice today? They are not. That kind of stack ranking practice, that went out the window many years ago. We had a brilliant chair in our department who decided that instead of that, we're going to model the extent to which faculty collaborate with each other on papers and grants and projects. And so he used this sophisticated modeling program to actually produce a diagram that would show all the interpersonal connections within our department. And he printed that out and our department's collaboration network diagram has now been posted in our front office.
这些名单今天还在实行吗？已经不实行了。那种堆栈排名实践，多年前就已经被淘汰了。我们系里有一位出色的系主任，他决定不再那样做，而是我们要对教员之间在论文、资助和项目上合作的程度进行建模。因此，他使用了一个复杂的建模程序来生成一个图表，展示我们系内的所有人际连接。他把它打印了出来，我们系的合作网络图现在已经贴在了我们的前办公室里。
So right by the faculty mailboxes, every day when you walk in and you pick up your mail, you're reminded about that value as an organization, as a department. I think this goes to how important it is to really challenge the dominant and competitive culture of genius that exists in so many of our fields and certainly in academia. We talked earlier in this conversation
所以就在教员邮箱旁边，每天你走进来取信时，你都会被提醒作为组织、作为系里的那种价值观。我认为这说明了真正挑战存在于我们许多领域、当然还有学术界中的占主导地位且竞争激烈的天才文化是多么重要。我们在这次谈话的早些时候讨论过
about your survey of college students' perceptions of their instructors' mindsets. There were a lot of fixed mindset comments, but the survey also provided examples of messages that teachers could send that students perceived as growth-oriented. Can you read out some of them as well, Mary? Sure. Some of the examples that we found in this data was students saying things like, I had
关于你对大学生对其导师心态看法的调查。有很多固定型思维的评论，但调查也提供了老师可以发送的、学生认为是成长导向的信息的例子。玛丽，你能读出其中的一些吗？当然。我们在这些数据中发现的一些例子是学生们说的话，比如，我曾有
one math professor who described a student from a previous semester who said he was not naturally good at math, but the student regularly attended office hours, asked questions, and ended up getting the highest grade in the class. He, the teacher, told the story to encourage us, the students, to ask questions and attend office hours. Another example that we saw in the data, the students in my class had no idea how to write a scientific paper, but the professor had a 72-hour policy where all students could turn in their paper 72 hours before it was due and the TA would read it and give them comments. This helped teach
一位数学教授，他描述了前一个学期的一名学生，该学生说他天生数学不好，但该学生经常去答疑时间（office hours），问问题，最终得了班上的最高分。他，也就是老师，讲这个故事是为了鼓励我们这些学生去问问题并参加答疑时间。我们在数据中看到的另一个例子是，我班上的学生根本不知道如何写一篇科学论文，但教授有一个72小时的政策，所有学生都可以在截止日期前72小时提交论文，助教会阅读并给出意见。这有助于教导
us what you did right, what you did wrong, and how to fix it before it was submitted for a grade. Another example is my math teacher says, you're all smart enough to get an A. However, you're going to find a few topics difficult across the term. If this is the case, please come to my office hours so we can discuss the topic more in depth. I'm here to help you. And then finally, my professor always gave the class advice about how to improve and do better in the course, especially after the class got their grades back from tests,
我们你做对了什么，做错了什么，以及如何在提交评分之前修复它。另一个例子是我的数学老师说，你们都足够聪明，可以得A。然而，你们会发现整个学期中有几个主题很难。如果是这种情况，请来我的答疑时间，以便我们可以更深入地讨论这个主题。我来这里是为了帮助你们。最后，我的教授总是就如何在课程中改进和做得更好向全班提出建议，特别是当全班从测试中拿回成绩后，
he always told us how we could improve. And I understand that in corporate settings, there are company-wide practices that can also be designed to convey a growth mindset. I understand that Microsoft was once notorious for having a fixed mindset culture. It used to practice the stack ranking procedure that we talked about earlier.
他总是告诉我们如何才能改进。据我了解，在企业环境中，也有一些全公司范围的实践，可以旨在传达成长型思维。据我所知，微软曾经以拥有固定型思维文化而闻名。它过去常常实行我们之前讨论过的堆栈排名程序。
What was it like to work at Microsoft then and now? In 2012, a reporter did an in-depth investigation into Microsoft and interviewed a bunch of current and former employees. And every single one of them who were interviewed cited stacked ranking as the most destructive process inside Microsoft. They said it was driving untold numbers of people out.
那时和现在在微软工作是什么感觉？2012年，一名记者对微软进行了深入调查，采访了一群现任和前任员工。所有接受采访的人都将堆栈排名列为微软内部最具破坏性的流程。他们说这把无数的人逼走了。
And so the practice at Microsoft required managers to really grade employees against each other and rank them on a scale of one to five. And so if you had a team of 10 people, even if that team was the highest performing and most innovative team within the organization, you still knew that no matter how good everyone was, two people were going to get a great review,
因此，微软的做法要求经理们真正对员工进行互相评分，并按一到五的等级进行排名。所以如果你有一个10人的团队，即使该团队是组织中表现最好、最具创新性的团队，你仍然知道无论每个人有多好，两个人将获得极好的评价，
seven people are going to get the mediocre review, and one was going to get a terrible review. And of course, as we've talked about, this led employees to really focus on competing with each other. So much so that when Sachin Nadella became CEO, he pointed to this infamous cartoon, and it has an organizational chart showing guns pointing in every direction. And he said, this is the Microsoft that he inherited.
七个人将获得平庸的评价，一人将获得糟糕的评价。当然，正如我们所讨论的，这导致员工真正专注于互相竞争。以至于当萨蒂亚·纳德拉（Satya Nadella）成为首席执行官时，他指着这幅臭名昭著的漫画，上面有一个组织结构图，显示枪口指向各个方向。他说，这就是他继承的微软。
So in this system, even if you achieved your goals, even if you achieved everything that was on your plate and everything that was expected of you, it didn't guarantee safety because it was always possible that a colleague, right, could achieve better than you. And so what the experience was like in that company was that employees were really focused on suppressing their colleagues, gaming the system and withholding information, right? In 2013, Microsoft threw out their stack ranking system and instead Satya Nadella's wife
所以在这种系统中，即使你达到了你的目标，即使你完成了你盘子里的所有事情以及对你的所有期望，它也不能保证安全，因为同事总是很有可能表现得比你好。所以在那家公司的体验是，员工真正专注于压制他们的同事、钻系统的空子和隐瞒信息，对吧？2013年，微软废除了他们的堆栈排名系统，取而代之的是萨蒂亚·纳德拉的妻子
actually shared with him Carol Dweck's book on mindset. And he was so inspired by this. He decided, I'm really gonna take this mindset idea and see if we can shift the mindset culture of this organization through a lot of these practices and policies that we've been talking about today. So, stack ranking goes out the door. Now, there's a new evaluation system that has just been unrolled, looking at people's potential, looking at the opportunities a manager has been giving to individuals, and people's responses to those opportunities for growth and development.
实际上与他分享了卡罗尔·德维克（Carol Dweck）关于心态的书。他深受启发。他决定，我真的要采纳这个心态理念，看看我们是否可以通过我们今天一直在讨论的许多这些实践和政策来改变这个组织的心态文化。因此，堆栈排名被抛弃了。现在，有一个新评估系统刚刚推出，着眼于人们的潜力，着眼于经理给予个人的机会，以及人们对这些成长和发展机会的反应。
One of the things that they did was also revamp the talent identification system within Microsoft. And by doing that, it involves multiple days of the CEO and his executive team sort of sitting down with all the leaders of the different arms of the organization and talking about individuals who are seen as having growth potential, who really seem to be able to be benefited by stretch assignments and by moving to different teams, taking on new roles within the organization,
他们所做的事情之一还包括重组微软内部的人才识别系统。通过这样做，它涉及首席执行官及其执行团队与组织各个部门的所有领导坐在一起多天，讨论那些被视为具有成长潜力、似乎真正能够从挑战性任务以及调到不同团队、承担组织内的新角色中受益的个人，
or actually getting different resources in order to go deeper with the things that they seem to be developing. And by doing this, they really get a sense of how the organization can actually support a larger set of individuals than would otherwise be recognized in encouraging a culture of growth is that people will say, you know, you're being too soft or lenient and that these things will not produce success. Do you hear that worry among the institutions you work with that moving from this fixed mindset
或者实际上获得不同的资源，以便更深入地研究他们似乎正在发展的事物。通过这样做，他们真正了解了组织如何能够支持比原本被认可的更多的一群人，在鼓励成长文化时，人们会说，你知道，你太软弱或宽容了，这些东西不会产生成功。在与你合作的机构中，你是否听到过这种担忧，即从这种固定型思维
to a culture of growth mindset will create a culture of leniency? I do hear that we are, quote-unquote, lowering standards when we are creating these cultures of growth. But actually, our research shows just the opposite, that actually high performers perform better in cultures of growth because these environments
转向成长型思维文化会创造一种纵容的文化？我确实听到过这种说法，即当我们在创造这些成长文化时，我们是在“降低标准”。但实际上，我们的研究表明恰恰相反，实际上高绩效者在成长文化中表现得更好，因为这些环境
are more rigorous and more supportive. They expect more from individuals, right? And they expect more from a broader swath of individuals than a culture of genius does. We see, if you imagine this in a classroom context, what we see in the data from very large introductory STEM classes is that when students perceive their instructor to have more of a growth mindset,
更加严格且更具支持性。他们对个人期望更高，对吧？而且他们对更广泛的人群的期望比天才文化更高。我们看到，如果你在课堂环境中想象这一点，我们在非常大型的入门STEM课程的数据中看到的是，当学生认为他们的导师具有更多的成长型思维时，
it's not that it's rainbows and sunshine and unicorns all day long. Students actually report a good amount of frustration and a good amount of annoyance sometimes in those classes because the instructor holds everyone to such high standards of continuous growth and development. So even if you're already doing well, even those individuals should show some growth and development in their trajectory. And it can be really rigorous and difficult in these environments. And so this is one of those myths about mindset culture that cultures of growth are soft and always affirming and less rigorous, dumbing down the standards.
并不是说整天都是彩虹、阳光和独角兽。学生们实际上报告说，在这些课堂上有相当多的挫折感和相当多的烦恼，因为导师对每个人都抱有如此高的持续成长和发展标准。因此，即使你已经做得很好，即使是这些个人也应该在他们的轨迹中展示出一些成长和发展。在这些环境中，这可能非常严格和困难。因此，这是关于心态文化的迷思之一，即成长文化是温和的、总是肯定的、较不严格的、降低了标准。
And actually we see just the opposite in the data. So all of us can be culture creators in our own lives and in the lives of our families and workplaces. And I understand that you and your husband Victor have thought about these questions in the context of your marriage. Can you describe one domain for me where you had maybe a fixed mindset about Victor and he had a fixed mindset about you and how you've tried to move from that to more of a growth
而实际上我们在数据中看到了完全相反的情况。所以我们所有人都可以成为自己生活中、家庭生活和工作场所中的文化创造者。据我所知，你和你的丈夫维克托（Victor）在你们的婚姻背景下思考过这些问题。你能为我描述一个领域吗？在这个领域里，你可能对维克托有固定型思维，而他对你也有固定型思维，你们是如何试图从那种思维转变为更多的成长型
mindset? You know, anytime you have two or more people that interact with each other, you're gonna have a mindset culture, right? About how you think about each one of your skills and abilities. So my husband Victor and I have really tried to notice where we're putting ourselves and each other into these kinds of fixed-minded boxes,
思维的？你知道，任何时候只要有两个或更多的人互相交往，你就会有一种心态文化，对吧？关于你如何看待你们各自的技能和能力。所以我的丈夫维克托和我真的试图注意到我们把我们自己和彼此置于哪种固定型思维的框框中，
and to do some small experiments that kind of challenge these assumptions, and showing ourselves, reminding ourselves that we're fully capable of growth and change. So one of my fixed mindset beliefs about Victor is that he's too modest, he's self-effacing, but he's also, frankly, in his own right, a badass. He, the work he does in his job as a law professor is really to
并做一些小实验来挑战这些假设，向自己展示、提醒自己我们完全有能力成长和改变。所以关于维克托，我的固定型思维信念之一是他太谦虚了、不爱出风头，但坦率地说，他本身也是一个狠角色。他在法学教授的工作中所做的工作，实际上是
transform courts and judicial systems nationally. So what I've done is to really work to notice and highlight for myself and for him different places where I see him putting forward his findings and his contributions in a way that makes him feel comfortable but also in a way that he shows what he has discovered. For his part, Victor's fixed mindset belief about me is somewhat accurate, that I enjoy systems and really being in control. And so he's made a lot of efforts to say something to me when he notices that I'm sitting back and encouraging other people to call the shots.
在全国范围内改造法院和司法系统。所以我所做的是真正努力去注意并为我自己和为他强调不同的地方，在这些地方我看到他以一种让他感到舒适的方式提出他的发现和贡献，同时也以一种展示他所发现的东西的方式。就他而言，维克托对我的固定型思维信念在某种程度上是准确的，即我喜欢系统并且真正喜欢掌控一切。因此，当他注意到我退居二线并鼓励其他人发号施令时，他付出了很多努力对我说些什么。
I'll also share that this summer, Victor noticed that I'd really developed an interest in the cello. So he encouraged me to find a teacher here in Bloomington, and he's done a million little things to really take things off my plate so I can go to lessons and practice at home. And so I think that in personal relationships, when we can support the aspirational selves we really like to be and who we'd like to become, it can inspire in us a courage to kind of seek out more of those cultures of growth and create those cultures of growth for ourselves. How good are you at the cello right now? Well, I will tell you that I just graduated from being able to pick Mary Had a Little Lamb and Twinkle Twinkle
我还想分享的是，今年夏天，维克托注意到我对大提琴产生了真正的兴趣。因此他鼓励我在布卢明顿找一位老师，并且他做了无数件小事来减轻我的负担，这样我就可以去上课并在家里练习。所以我认为在个人关系中，当我们能够支持我们真正想成为的、渴望成为的自我时，它可以激发我们的勇气去寻求更多那种成长文化，并为我们自己创造这些成长文化。你现在大提琴拉得怎么样？嗯，我会告诉你，我刚刚从能够拨弄《玛丽有只小羊羔》（Mary Had a Little Lamb）和《小星星》（Twinkle Twinkle）
to bowing and it is a revolution. It is so fantastic. I'm really looking forward to where it's going to take me. Will you share some of your playing with us, Mary? Absolutely not. I do have the cello in the other room, but still, no, it's too embarrassing. I was going to let it go, but then I remembered Mary had spent the last 45 minutes telling me that we all needed to have a growth mindset. The essence of having a growth mindset? To have the courage to be a beginner. I reminded
毕业到能够拉弓了，这是一场革命。太棒了。我真的很期待它会把我带向何方。玛丽，你会跟我们分享一些你的演奏吗？绝对不。我确实把大提琴放在另一个房间里，但还是不行，太尴尬了。我本来想放过它的，但后来我想起玛丽在过去的45分钟里一直在告诉我，我们所有人都需要拥有成长型思维。拥有成长型思维的本质是什么？要有做初学者的勇气。我提醒了
her of her own lesson. Oh gosh, Shankar, have we created a culture of growth that's not going to judge this performance? Absolutely. Okay, we'll see how this goes. Mary Murphy is the author of Cultures of Growth, How the New Science of Mindset Can Transform Individuals, Teams, and Organizations. Mary, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
她她自己的课。哦天哪，尚卡尔（Shankar），我们是不是创造了一种不会评判这种表演的成长文化？绝对的。好吧，我们来看看进展如何。玛丽·墨菲（Mary Murphy）是《成长文化：心态的新科学如何改变个人、团队和组织》（Cultures of Growth, How the New Science of Mindset Can Transform Individuals, Teams, and Organizations）一书的作者。玛丽，谢谢你今天加入我的《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。
Thank you, Shankar. It's been such a pleasure. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha that. I hope you enjoyed it. It was fun for me. Bye. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paw, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week, we continue our Innovation 2.0 series with a look at a secret superpower that we all have. It might make you rethink your interactions with the people around you.
谢谢你，尚卡尔。非常荣幸。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈.希望你喜欢。这对我来说很有趣。再见。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-帕（Annie Murphy-Paw）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。下周，我们将继续我们的“创新2.0”系列，看看我们所有人都拥有的一种秘密超能力。这可能会让你重新思考你与周围人的互动。
You have these two people interacting with one another and they're both so focused on their own personal anxieties and insecurities and concerns with embarrassment that they don't realize that the other person is feeling that way too. If you're enjoying our Innovation 2.0 series, please share it with two or three people who might find it useful. Maybe that's a co-worker or your spouse or a friend in your book club.
你有这两个人互相互动，他们都如此专注于他们自己的个人焦虑、不安以及对尴尬的担忧，以至于他们没有意识到对方也有这种感觉。如果你喜欢我们的“创新2.0”系列，请把它分享给两三个可能会觉得它有用的人。也许那是你的同事、你的配偶或你读书俱乐部的朋友。
No matter who you choose, your word of mouth recommendations make a huge difference in helping us connect new listeners to the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain. We really appreciate your support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论你选择谁，你的口碑推荐都在帮助我们将新听众连接到我们在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨的理念方面发挥了巨大作用。我们非常感谢你的支持。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来发表评论。